chug some breast milk or down a fresca
because it's time to throw your son off
the roof
after more than a year the boys season 2
is finally here and it feels like i've
been waiting longer than the deep in
sandusky ohio
in this video we'll be going over the
first three episodes some cool [ __ ] you
might have missed and theories on what's
to come before we begin
make sure to like and subscribe as i'll
be covering every episode this season
but first f's in the chat for lucy
this opening scene is low-key hilarious
with an assistant trying to figure out
who ordered the baby kale salad as
executives from vaught industries go
over the contract that will
undoubtedly result in the deaths of
thousands if not millions of people
if you remember from season one vaughn
was involved in a secretive plan to
distribute compound v
to terrorists in order to garner
lucrative defense deals with the us
government and here we see black noir
decapitate a super terrorist whose power
is hold on let me check my notes
exploding himself as it seems these
contracts are underway
translucent finally gets a funeral love
the open casket which is a fun nod to
him being invisible even though in
season 1 he was exploded to smithereens
there's this great juxtaposition between
starlight living this celebrity dream
life while huey lives in an absolute
dump
both of them are in their own kind of
prison huey will later team up with
starlight who he had a romantic
connection with in season one
look they even touch knees they both
want to bring down
vaut so huey devises a plan that if they
can just get access to some compound v
they can prove to the world that heroes
are not born
they're made not only that but most of
these heroes were given compound v
without their consent half our own
heroes don't know they have compound
being their veins
this is best seen through the deep who
is filled with rage when he finds out
his childhood of
hearing fish scream and developing gills
which made him a laughingstock was a
result of this compound and not some
freak genetic defect
he'll eventually team up with another
hero named eagle the archer and a woman
named carol from the church of the
collective
not much is known about this church but
the fact eagle and carol want him to
overcome his
demons so he can be a member of the
seven again hint that they have some
more nefarious plan
the power of having one of their members
in the seven would likely be a huge boon
for the church
i definitely think something fishy is
going on here god damn these puns
are terrible we also learn of the
church's leader alastair adana we
haven't seen him yet but he'll play a
bigger role in future episodes portrayed
by croatian actor goran viznich the
seven are looking for a new member
sorry no disabled people allowed in
episode 1 we'll be introduced to
stormfront who looks like she'll be a
new adversary for homelander as she
begins to take the limelight away from
him
as we'll witness in episode 3 she's not
to be [ __ ] with meanwhile starlight
blackmails a former capes for christ
friend who has the ability to regrow
parts of his body
for an extra ground i'll let you drop
off my dick this is gekko named after
the lizard who can regrow its appendages
he works as a lab rat for vote giving
him the ability to access compound v
which he eventually gives to starlight
but a train finds out about this
in last season's finale a train
overdosed on compound v
and was saved by starlight even though
he found out that starlight was working
with huey to bring down
vaughn as we'll see in the first three
episodes a train still suffers from the
after effects of his addiction
clutching his heart after being at the
club all night and again
inside the tunnels frenchie and the boys
have been shacking up with a group of
drug dealers but unbeknownst to them
these dealers have also been engaging in
some good old-fashioned human
trafficking [ __ ] gets out of hand when
one of the passengers flips over this
boat which
kimiko realizes is her brother kenji as
children kimiko and kenji lost their
parents and were kidnapped by the
shining light liberation
army a group designated as a terrorist
organization
from that day kimiko lost her ability to
speak and thus her and her brother
created their own version of sign
language
something frenchie later asked to learn
that might come into play for future
episodes and spark
a greater love between the two kenji
like kimiko was infused with compound v
giving him the power to move objects
with his hands when kemiko finds out
that kenji has been brainwashed by the
shining light
she realizes she'll have to turn him
into the boys before he does any further
damage
meanwhile the boys enlist the help of
cia deputy director susan raynor hoping
to make a deal for their safety in
return to bringing in
kenji but the meeting doesn't go to plan
when her head spontaneously explodes
now you might think that it's kenji who
did this but i don't think it is for one
we haven't seen him explode people like
that and
two you'd think if he saw his long-lost
sister there his first priority would be
to see her and not explode some random's
head in the season 2 trailer there's a
quick
shot of this soup exploding some people
we don't know who she is yet but she's
likely our culprit
we also get a creepy history lesson from
vaught president gustavo i mean stan
edgar who tells us that vaught's founder
frederick vaught
was the cheap physician at the dachau
concentration camp during world war
ii it's there he developed compound v by
experimenting on jews
only later to be pardoned by roosevelt
after aiding the american military the
boys also see the return of billy
butcher who we last saw the finale
finding out his wife is still alive and
conceived a child with homelander
bonus points if you figured out the
actor who plays homeland or son in
season 1
is completely different than the one in
season 2. he wakes up 3 hours after
these events outside a tony cicero's in
fort worth indiana
where he quickly writes down as much as
he possibly knows about the location of
his wife
like the yellow roof temperature and
large pine trees
homelander wants to turn his son into a
spitting image of him he's disappointed
at his shitty ball throwing and that his
mother is turning him into a quote [ __ ]
we do know his son has
powers we saw his eyes turn red at the
end of season one
homelander even throws him off the roof
in an effort to make him fly which i
guess is the superhero equivalent of
throwing your child in the pool to see
if they can swim he wants his son ryan
to have a good childhood raised by a
mother and father since homelander
himself grew up in a lab with no one to
love him but as we'll later find out
ryan is in his own kind of truman show
housed within a compound
never having gone beyond its borders
maeve's arc these first three episodes
is
fairly subdued picking up on her
relationship with elena
and concerned that homelander if he
finds out about it will
kill her expect this to play a bigger
role in episodes to come as
elena's death will likely result in
maeve switching allegiances
should anything happen to her with the
cia deputy director killed
butcher goes to an old friend grace for
her help in coordinating a deal with the
feds
if they can catch the terrorist soup
billy can get his wife back and the
boy's names can be cleared
but as they're making their way to the
cia safe house the deep tries to stop
them in an attempt to get back into the
seven
even commandeering a giant whale named
lucy to block their path
also just a big shout out to patton
oswalt who voiced his gills with the
seven hot on their tails the boys
venture into the tunnels where
homelander forces starlight to kill hugh
this was the tensest scene of the first
three episodes and i gotta say i didn't
see the kenji save where he buries
homelander under a [ __ ] ton of rubble
this also allows kenji to escape who is
pursued by stormfront who we get to see
use her incredible powers
and total disregard for civilians of
course avot uses this opportunity to
paint themselves
as the heroes even though word about
compound v was just made public
something stan edgar is trying to clear
up by saying that it was a rogue group
of scientists under the command of now
dead
madeleine stillwell who were responsible
for this the final
episode ends with homelander pissed at
stormfront's announcement as a new
member of the seven
something he had no choice in and if
there's one thing we've learned you
never want to piss off homeland
those are the big events of the first
three episodes i know i couldn't get to
everything but my
individual episodes will be much more in
depth so make sure you're subscribed for
that
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember
you